Adorable story alert!
So I was hanging out with my 2-year-old second
cousin in the ocean in Florida
and we're jumping up and down with the waves and it's fun but then the water got all calm and I said,
"Oh, no more waves!," because, like, that's the top tier of communication I'm going for with a 2-year-old,
but then he said "Don't worry, there'll be
more!"
And I was like, "How do you know?"
And he was like, "It's a cycle!"
Yes! It is a cycle!
The Earth is filled with cycles!
And if my 2-year-old second cousin knows it
you should know it too!
The universe is the great recycler.
All of the stuff we have on Earth, every last
particle of matter or calorie of energy has
been around since the Big Bang.
It just keeps getting repurposed over and
over again.
And when it comes to matter, at least, the
Earth is essentially a closed system.
All the matter gets passed around in continuous
biogeochemical cycles,
which are pathways for molecules like water
or elements like carbon and nitrogen and phosphorous
to move through all of the Earth's various
ecological and geological compartments.
Now of course we couldn't possibly talk about how all matter gets cycled around Earth in one video,
'cause the Earth is pretty big,
but consider this as an introduction to biogeochemical
cycles starring my two personal favorites:
carbon and water.
[Theme Music]
Now I'm sure you already know about at least
one type of planet-wide recycling because
it's the most obvious to us:
the hydrologic cycle which describes how water moves on, above, and below the surface of the Earth
driven by the energy supplied by the Sun and
the wind.
In talking about the hydrologic cycle it's
most useful to think about all of the water
on Earth being held in a series of reservoirs.
The ocean, for instance, or the atmosphere
in the form of clouds or in polar ice caps.
So not only does water cycle through different
places,
it also takes different forms in different
places in the cycle: liquid, solid, or gas.
And since it's a cycle there is no beginning and no end, so where we start our discussion is arbitrary,
but we're going to start it off with precipitation.
Rain, hail, snow, sleet, graupel, all of that
stuff is precipitation.
It happens when water that's being held in
the atmosphere condenses,
or turns from a gas into a liquid and then occasionally freezes into a solid, right up in the air.
The opposite of condensation, of course, it
evaporation, the conversion of a liquid into a gas
and when a substance converts straight from
a solid to a gas that's sublimation
and when it's from a gas to a solid that's
deposition.
And now you know.
But back to condensation.
It is responsible for the formation of clouds,
which happens when air containing water vapor rises and cools,
or is compressed to the point that it can no longer be a gas.
At this point, the vapor forms droplets.
This is the same thing you see happening on
your glass of ice tea on a humid day.
The water in the air around the glass gets
cold, and turns from gas into liquid.
So a cloud is just a big pile of condensed water droplets, in a sense, it's a gigantic floating reservoir.
Clouds are a handy feature of the hydrologic
cycle,
because as they drift over the landscape they
move water around the globe.
So water that evaporates over the ocean can
be deposited somewhere else.
Otherwise, if water always got deposited right
where it evaporated,
the precipitation would be almost always right
over the ocean,
because that's where most of the evaporation
on Earth takes place.
So wind moves clouds, and as water keeps condensing
clouds get heavier and heavier
until our old friend gravity takes over and
pulls the condensed droplets to the ground
in the form of rain or in the form of snow
or hail or sleet or graupel.
So now the water's on the ground,
but gravity continues to work on it pulling it towards its resting place wherever that might be.
It either pulls the water across the surface of the land to the lowest point in a process called runoff,
or it pulls it underground.
Water can be trapped or stored for a little
while in places like lakes and ponds and wetlands,
but most of the water that falls as precipitation
gets pulled lower and lower and lower
as runoff through the creeks and streams and
rivers until it reaches the ocean.
In really cold places, water of course freezes and hangs around as ice in places for thousands of years at a time,
like at the poles and glaciers and on mountaintops, but when it melts, most of it too runs off into the ocean.
So you see where this is going.
Oceans are a big deal -- they're pretty much
the biggest deal.
They're the reason that we have the hydrologic
cycle in the first place.
They're also the reason that we have awesome
stuff like weather, and life, on Earth.
The weird thing about oceans though is that
they're salty.
And there is a reason for this!
As water runs to the ocean it erodes minerals like salt from soil and carries it to the ocean.
Now water heading to the ocean may not taste
salty but the salt's in there.
But here's the thing: when the water evaporates again, the salt doesn't evaporate with it, it gets left behind.
You keep this up for a few billion years with
the pure water evaporating from the ocean
and returning with tiny amounts of salt and that's your recipe for a billion cubic kilometers of brine.
And all of this shows us that the world's oceans are literally the last stop for all the liquid water on Earth.
The only way to get out of there is through
evaporation and that leaves all your minerals behind.
Now living things also have their role to
play in the hydrologic cycle,
and both plants and animals that break down carbohydrates to produce energy produces water as a waste product.
So we lose water through evaporation from our skin and exhale water vapor and of course we pee it out.
Indeed most organisms on Earth are made mostly
of water,
although that water cycles in and out of us
pretty quickly.
In plants, water is sucked up through the
roots and moves up to the leaves
(the gas exchange organs) where it evaporates
quickly.
This process is called evapotranspiration. And since there are so many plants here on Earth
it's responsible for a good amount of the
water that enters the atmosphere.
This process is essentially the opposite of condensation in that it turns liquid water into gas.
The energy of the sun drives evaporation whether it's the surface of the ocean or from treetops and leaves,
and then once all of that water evaporates into the atmosphere we're right back where we started.
It's a cycle!
So now that you know a little bit about the
hydrologic cycle,
it's a little easier to understand how the
carbon cycle works.
Carbon is one of the most abundant elements in the universe and here on Earth it's always on the move,
just like water, jumping from one reservoir
to the next.
And that's a good thing because
A) all living things require carbon for their
structure and to fuel their bodies
and B) it's a big component in a bunch of
non-living things as well.
It's in rocks, in the ocean, trapped in ice.
Plus, it's in the atmosphere, where it helps
regulate the temperature.
Without carbon dioxide Earth would basically
be a frozen wasteland,
so lucky for us, there's a whole pants-load
of carbon out there, 'cause we need it!
Let's start off with the carbon in living
things.
If you were to take all of the water out of
your body,
carbon would constitute about half of what remained in the little pile of dust that used to be you.
And the first biological carbon reservoir
is plants.
They absorb a bunch of carbon dioxide out of the atmosphere because they need it to photosynthesize.
But CO2 is also one of the by-products of respiration, the process by which they use that energy.
So plants take in carbon dioxide from the
atmosphere during photosynthesis
and then release CO2 back out into the atmosphere
during their respiration process to make ATP
for all their cellular functions.
And right now, you're like,
"Wait-wait-wait-no isn't it the deal that
plants get to take in all the carbon dioxide
and animals get to breathe it out?"
Well, yes and no; it's just that plants take
in more CO2 from the atmosphere than they
give off though respiration.
The rest is like their profit; it's what becomes
the body of the plant.
That's right, that big-ol' massive tree, all
that mass, came from gas. Pretty cool.
So carbon absorbed by plants has three possible
fates.
It can be respired back into the atmosphere,
it can be eaten by an animal,
or it can be present when the plant dies.
And if a tree falls in the right kind of forest,
and it's not allowed to decompose normally because a bunch of other plants all fell right on top of it,
and they die and they get buried and squished
together and form rocks like coal.
We call these carbon-rich geological deposits
fossil fuels.
Lately one of humanity's very favorite pastimes
is digging up all of this carbon
in the form of carbon and natural gas, and
burning it to fuel our, pretty much everythings.
But I'll get to that later.
Another extremely important carbon reservoir
is the ocean.
Now carbon dioxide dissolves really easily
in water,
and once it's in there all of it's used by
phytoplankton
(tiny plant-like organisms that form the base
for the marine food chain).
They use it to do photosynthesis and they
also use it to form calcium carbonate shells.
And when these guys die, their shells settle
to the bottom of the ocean, pile up,
become compressed and over time, make rocks
like limestone.
Now limestone, obviously doesn't burn super
well, so it's not considered a fossil fuel,
but as limestone deposits are eroded by water, the calcium carbonate is broken down to eventually form,
among other things, carbon dioxide and carbonic
acid.
We make lime and cement by heating limestone, which produces a pretty good amount of carbon dioxide.
And when we do burn fossil fuels such as coal
and petroleum products and natural gases
it also releases carbon in the form of carbon
dioxide that's been stored for hundreds of
millions of years in the geosphere,
which is just a fancy science-y word for Earth-rocks.
This process is what started the atmosphere carbon dioxide rising like crazy in the past couple of hundred years.
And the excess of the carbon in the atmosphere
causes global climate change,
because CO2 in the atmosphere causes some of the sun's energy from re-radiating back out into space.
So yeah, our planet has been getting warmer
because we've been burning through this reservoir
of carbon that we had locked underground.
This is causing all kinds of problems that
we can see already,
and it's very likely to keep causing bigger
and bigger problems with time.
And the situation could be helped a lot if
we could just stop unlocking all of that carbon
and spitting it into the atmosphere,
but in some respects we don't even have control
over the situation any more, because of ice.
Remember how I said that carbon is often trapped
in ice?
Well, in places like Siberia, and northern Canada and Alaska, cold places that also have plants,
they contain huge carbon reserves that are trapped in permafrost (ground that's frozen year-round).
These places are basically frozen wetlands that add another layer of dead plant matter each year.
But as permafrost melts, these dead plants
decompose,
and huge amounts of carbon dioxide and methane
are released into the atmosphere,
creating a positive feedback loop.
Our carbon burning lifestyle is releasing
this other huge carbon reservoir,
which keep the whole greenhouse effect going
with or without us. Just sayin'
Sorry to end on such a frightening and depressing
note,
but the stability of the global climate is
not as stable as we would like it to be,
and the fact that we're throwing it out of
whack is one of the most important reasons
to study ecology in the first place.
This episode of Crash Course was written by
myself, Jesslyn Shields, and Blake de Pastino.
Our technical director is Nick Jenkins who is also our editor and is also standing behind the camera right now.
Graphics are courtesy of Amber Bushnell and Peter Winkler, and our sound designer is Michael Aranda.
If you want to review any of what we went over in today's episode, check out the table of contents over there.
And if you have any questions or comments
or corrections or ideas for us, we're on Facebook
and Twitter,
and, of course, down in the comments below.